when it comes to your acting career is
there anything that you do every day no
matter what whether it's look in the
mirror and say I can do this whether
it's half cup coffee what what is it
every day you do no matter what
that helps toward the acting career not
just getting up and being a human but it
helps tour the acting career well I
think keeping sharp in your mind I I do
a lot of like exercises but like for
instance before I did this interview or
you know before I do an audition I will
go to a magazine or a book and I'll read
out loud for like two pages you know and
enunciate every word and push it out
because a lot of times I was getting
stuck in here you know when I do an
audition or working we're all get stuck
in here and I read daily just to like
sort of help pronunciate and I tell
other actors it's a great way before
auditions to really get that enunciation
it's just a read out loud for you know
two or three pages and you'll seal your
mouth getting warmed up and then you're
ready to go and then you don't have to
to worry about that you know because I
would worry about getting stuck you know
because the fear would get in there or
something like that or you know
auditions are frightening they are
terrifying as an actor I mean and
they're enjoyable too sometimes when
they go well oh but they're terrifying
you know even still like before an
audition I'll get sweaty hands and I'll
have to like talk myself down and it's a
process you know it's not it it's not a
natural process to go in and to subject
yourself to six or seven people in the
room the director the casting director
the producers who are all staring at you
like you know you have to perform and
you hope it goes well but it can be very
terrifying so anything that you can do
to alleviate that stress you know does
help so I'll read and then just get out
take my dog for a walk and
you know hang out with a on my friends
who I have a great friend base here
which is I think it's important when you
live in LA to have good friends because
again there are a lot of people here
that will just want to take and take and
take and maybe not appreciate you for
who you are so it's important to have
good good people around you you think
being nervous is a good thing as I know
for me people would say oh you calm down
your unit but I almost think that that
show then you care sure no I think
absolutely I think if you're not nervous
something's wrong with you you know I
think I think you need to go back to the
table and we assess what's going on with
you if you're not nervous about this
audition
you know then what's going on with you
you should be nervous you know I think
it does it absolutely means that you
care you know you want to put on your
best and you want to want you want to do
your best you know but it is it's very
nerve-wracking and you know I get
nervous before auditions still I've been
doing this for 22 years you know before
the events before I have to get up and
talk to you know big crowd sure you know
this is not again I don't think we
should be complacent or too relaxed
which is interesting because in our work
we have to appear relaxed you know but
inside just like oh my god I'm at a
freakout right I have a huge director
looking at you or they brought in their
main actor to to read with you you know
you got to put that out of your brain
you know I remember doing an audition
with Brad Pitt for the Mexican I got
close on a on an audition and my manager
at the time says oh yeah you could be
reading with Brad Pitt so nonchalantly
like oh okay sure but you have to go in
and you have to put that aside and you
know I got to audition with Brad Pitt
and do a scene and how cool is that how
fun is that so you never know there's a
lot of fun in auditions and you get
surprises like that sometimes
where certain actors who they'll bring
them in to read with you man didn't end
up getting the part but just being able
to go in and read with somebody that you
admire it's you've won already for me I
get nervous and I get clumsy you were
there ever times when you got so nervous
but you had to maybe go for a walk
around the block or yeah I think yeah
usually I'll have to there's an exercise
we just tense up all of your body just a
for an audition you know I'll be in the
waiting room and it's so funny to walk
in to watch other actors do their thing
in the room you know I'm not one that's
very like I thought about it oh you got
the actors in the room first aid your
stuff out loud and like don't do that go
outside can't stand that don't be an
actor yeah I just don't you know what I
mean like preserve it go or go somewhere
else you know what I mean um but yeah
I'll do something world tense up your
entire body until and then you let it go
and then I like sort of relax the body
or you know whatever you got to do to
sort of relieve that stress and then a
lot of the times that nervous energy
helps because you get into the room and
then not just propel you through the
scene and you're like yeah I did it you
know they're like oh that was amazing
and then you can kind of like okay you
can follow in took a little bit more and
trust yourself which is hard to do do
you ever get so nervous that you can't
sleep yeah
I'm not a very good sleeper I'm not a
very good sleeper and I dead
that over time here in LA has I went
from being a really good sleeper to and
I just don't sleep very well in this
town I think I don't know that a lot of
people do here I don't know it's
possible but I think it's a collective
sort of energy that discount has right
it's everybody's trying to like you know
so I don't have a lot of good friends
that I know of that sleep very well you
know but yeah I get nervous especially
before an audition the night before or
or like set if I've got to go to set the
next day and work with you know a major
actor and I'm terrified of getting
steamrolled he hit the hook um it could
be very Terrace
sighing absolutely and then you get on
set and it's fine and you know the other
actors are there but there's always that
concern of getting the part like I'm not
going to be good enough and you have to
tell yourself I have to remind myself
you got the part
you know something you did work because
we'll get it be like I don't know what
I'm doing you know or you know I've been
in that situation you know the day of
and I'm like I don't know what I'm doing
and you get there and you meet the other
actors and it just falls into place so
yeah but from someone else who has a lot
of trouble sleeping
that 4 o'clock in the morning 3 o'clock
in the morning like the terror that go
through your mind any anything you do to
kind of alleviate that because that can
be really scary yeah yeah man should you
write it out or write it out until
you're able to fall back asleep but I'm
the same way I wake up at all weird
times and yes sleeping and they are not
friends but uh and I'm not really a map
taker either
I just can't fall asleep that easily
where I got so much going on here but
yeah do you read or the like for me I'll
watch videos on computer coding and it
usually puts me roughly what anyway yeah
like learning HTML like these YouTube
videos and it does help with are there
different things that help you I'm not
guess I should start because watching
these YouTube videos on different
coatings Jonna Chris yeah yeah happening
let me sleep run away so it so you'll
just go through it you're just ready to
write it out and you know hopefully it
works out you know and then once you get
on set the adrenaline takes over and
then later on you like you feel it
you know you'll be working on something
and you do a fight scene I won't feel
anything and then later that night
you'll go home you'll be like oh my god
what have I done about yourself because
then it seemed I don't care I'll I'll do
it I'll take a hit I'll do whatever it
takes you know you
your Adrenaline's going don't feel it
necessarily until you're taking a shower
and you're like this bruise no miss
bruise oh yes yes yes yes I was from
today so
you